for you've got a film here at the lff
this year in fact it's one of the
Garfield isn't it tell me about it yeah
it's fun girl song for Marion it's a
garlic screening which is obviously very
nice it's a film about an older couple
and acquire and full of pensioners who
sing sort of modern and cool songs and
also just about the relationships within
a family which is Terence Stamp Vanessa
Redgrave and Christopher Eccleston
you've got some big names that haven't
you what was it like working with those
guys I know it's really good there it
you know they've obviously got a wealth
of experience for you know all of them
and it you know in one way they were
just like working with any other actors
that you've done that you've worked with
before they all brought something very
different to the to the film including
Gemma Arterton who's also sort of very
prominent in the film you know every
actor is different every actor once a
different way and every actor is you
know that I've worked with thus far in
all the films I've done has been pretty
cool so it was a great experience
working with everyone it's been quite a
journey since London to write and hasn't
it for you I mean how's the experience
of filmmaking change for you and and how
can we expect you to style to be
evolving with this next film and I'd you
know I don't know what people are going
to think about the film it's a you know
a lot of people i think would think it
was different myself I would say
obviously the story is different but
there's still a lot of themes in terms
of character and morality and regret and
all that sort of stuff that's in all of
the films admittedly this one's a lot
more uplifting and moving and wherever
so I don't know I never look at my
career whatever career is in any sort of
path or way I'm just like look for the
next gig and forget what then I'm happy
where did the idea for this one come
from and it came from lots of different
things personal experience adores you
know some personal experience in the
film also you know just the idea of old
people still being in a relationship and
still having feelings and how they deal
with things you know and just sort of
seeing that's never too late
to change for anybody and also the fact
that old people can actually get up and
rock it you think that they're kind of
enough of the films with great mature
actors like these on screen and enough
fills for mature more mature audiences
out there I think definitely they're
starting to appear you know if you look
at the for example the the Marigold
Hotel Best Exotic Marigold Hotel did
really well there's another film called
quartet obviously which is in the film
in the festival as well and obviously
some for Marion which you know don't
necessarily Center only on old older
people but sort of feature them heavily
I mean it's good because you know a lot
of older people are retired got a bit of
money and you know senior citizens do
you get into the cinema cheaper so I
think that you know they shouldn't be
neglected in terms of a cinema going
audience why should they be coming to
see song for Marion because well
hopefully there's something in the film
that every single person will be able to
relate to different aspects for
different people and I think that one of
the things that's positive about the
film obviously I made it so I'm going to
say that is the fact that it does you
know it does touch people in a very
realistic way and it's almost like it's
okay to be moved by the film because
it's just about us well not me but us as
in people and next up for you I've got
to being Waterloo at one o'clock that's
next and after that I'm really there's a
few things knocking about I'm not sure
whoever wants to employ me first I think
I don't think something with Jennifer
Aniston coming up and you know that's
been talked about and it's still being
talked about and you know you just never
know until you're on set shooting you
never know what you're doing it
you